the speed Chess Championship is back and
bigger than ever
did he had to take the pawn on D7 the
2022 speed Chess Championship features
the most exciting lineup in SCC history
and over 100
000 in prizes representing the Next
Generation Are Notre Beck abdusa Torah
Arjun aragaisi nihal sarin and gukesh
domaraju defending their Elite status we
have Dimitri on draken Anish giri Maxim
Michelle agrav Wesley so
Lavon aronian
janapomnishi dingly Ren and Fabiano
caruana headlining this incredible field
are the reigning world chess champion
Magnus Carlson and the reigning speed
chess champion Hikaru Nakamura
these 14 combatants will be joined by
two qualifiers oh my God 96 86. oh my
goodness he missed it the speed Chess
Championship 2022 begins November 21st
fasten your speed belts